Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in the book of
seeking forgiveness,
seeking pardon from Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
and
we hear as is usual in all of the books
and chapter chapters of he will begin
by listing particular verses from the
Quran that bolster, prove, work towards,
expound upon whatever subject it is. And
then he follows that up with relevant
narrations.
And
he says he cites another narration
another verse here from Alan
which is a verse regarding the virtues
of tawa and seeking forgiveness from
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala.
[Silence]
So in the opening verses of surah Iran
verse number 15 161 17
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
in the previous verses mentions the two
things that people work towards two
kinds of people.
You have a people who are enamored
and enthralled
by the pleasures of this dunya
and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala lists
those pleasures
and he
is able to list all of those
pleasures. What do I mean by that?
Meaning that with respect to the dunya,
what what is there for anybody to have?
What is the greatest pleasure a person
may have?
[Silence]
So he mentioned six things. He says the
people people in general not just
non-Muslims Muslims as well because
he said regarding this verse he
commented on it and said we do in fact
love these things after Allah has
mentioned there's no problem with a
person naturally being inclined to these
things as long as it is within the
parameters of the guidance against the
boundaries of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
and as long as these things are not
something that you attach your heart to
that's the problem as the scholars of
Islam
of old would say never allow the dunya
or any aspect of the dunya a place in
your heart
place the dunya always firmly in your
hand because that is where tools belong.
Tools belong in your hand. They don't
belong in your heart. And so if you keep
the dunya in your hand at a distance,
but you use it, it will benefit you and
draw you closer to Allah.
And you reserve those places in your
heart for Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala and
the hereafter.
However, if you allow the dunya into
your heart, what happens? It will burn
you. Burn you down. It will hurt you. It
will harm you because the dunya will
always let you down.
Always.
The dunya will always let you down
eventually.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
that people are naturally inclined
and the dunya to them is adorned in
their eyes
and they have a love for the pleasures
of the dunya. What are the pleasures of
the dunya? He mentions the six chief
pleasures.
He mentions women. He mentions children.
He mentions
gold and silver, right? Money. He
mentions horses and and different types
of animals that you ride and carriages
etc. He mentions livestock and he
mentions harvest, farming. These are the
chief pleasures of the dunya. any other
type of pleasure can all be taken back
and rooted back to one of these six
types. Now, the dunya is pretty
pathetic. Why is it so pathetic? Because
you can actually list all of its
pleasures. You can boil them all down
into a short list that you can count on
two hands. That's it. That's all the
dunya has to offer. Nothing beyond that.
It it may have lots of categories of
that and lots of different types of that
and it looks very nice and illustrious
and it looks so vast and so many
opportunities because it's constantly
advertising itself. However, at the end
of the day, you can boil it down to
these six. And what's even more pathetic
is most of us will never have all of
these six. Most people will only have
one or two of these things. and they
will only have a portion of one or two
of these things, let alone all of them.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
he said those things they are the
momentary recreation
of the life of this dunya, the first
life. Remember whenever you see in the
Quran the word
it is taken from the word adunu
and that is that it is the closest it's
the first step in our journey to our
final abode. So it is the first step.
What is the first step? We're in the
first phase right? And that is these six
things. They are what all of the dunya
has to offer. Any pleasure you've ever
felt. Excess pleasure. It is always
rooted back to one of these six things.
He says that is and those are in a
nutshell the pleasures of this first
life.
But Allah has the best of abode, the
best of return, the best of arrival.
It lies with Allah. Notice the wording.
Meaning that the reward of the hereafter
resides where? With Allah.
That's all you need to really know about
the life of the hereafter is that it is
in the company of Allah.
It is with him. So in order to get that
reward, you have to go to him and be
with him to enjoy that reward.
That's the best of it. That can never be
topped. What is the greatest driving
force in all of human nature? Think
about it. The thing that pushes people
the most out of everything else,
it costs people their lives every single
day.
You see it all the time. People follow
and pursue this thing at their own
peril. You know what it is? Curiosity.
Think about it. You ever see if an
explosion went off down the street?
What's going to happen? People are going
to run to it. To it.
You would think that is
counterproductive. That is danger. You
would go, "No, but I got to see. I got
to see what's going on. I have to know.
I have to see. I can't. People, it beats
fear. 10 times out of 10.
Curiosity beats fear. 10 times out of
10. It beats anger. 10 times out of 10.
It beats all pursuits. Curiosity.
Because the human being is naturally
seeking and thirsty for knowledge.
That's what curiosity is. It is a
driving force
that drives people and propels to seek
knowledge. They want to know. Could you
imagine spending eternity not being able
to see past the veil of Allah? You don't
get to see him. The people of the
hellfire, what is their greatest
punishment? They will not get to see
Allah.
That's the greatest punishment.
The greatest reward of the people of the
hereafter they will be able to see Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala and sah Muslim
the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam tells us that Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala will tell the people of
paradise after they have entered
paradise he will say to them
would you me to increase you give
you more they will say
[Silence]
He they they will say what more could we
ask? You have saved us from the
hellfire, forgiven us our sins, entered
us into paradise in which we will have
everything that we could possibly want.
And at that point, Allah will remove the
veil between himself and the people of
paradise.
He says, "And when Allah removes that
veil, they will then look upon Allah and
they will find no pleasure nor any
satisfaction more beloved to them than
seeing Allah."
That's the greatest reward. And the
opposite is true for the people of the
hellfire. The greatest punishment is not
the flames, is not the boiling water, is
not the food, is not the smell, is not
the claustrophobia, it's not the heat.
It is being forbidden to ever, ever,
ever see Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. Not
even a glimpse, not even a little bit.
As a matter of fact, they will scream
for Allah and he will not answer them
and he will not speak to them. And they
will try to get the pe the the angels of
the gatekeepers of hell to intercede on
their behalf. And they will say, "Be
quiet. Don't speak to us."
And then after a while, when they
realize that there's no more hope
and there's no more point in screaming
because the screaming doesn't make
anything better. It actually makes
things worse.
Finally, finally, finally, after Allah
alone knows how how long, the only sound
that will be heard in the hellfire is
the churning of the fire and the intense
breathing of the people of the hellfire.
That's it. If you were to look upon the
people of the hellfire, there's no
sound. No one's talking anymore. No
one's screaming anymore.
It is just the sound of their breath and
their wheezing
and their panting and the sound of the
fire itself and its churning and its
chains and its flames and that is it.
and the and the people of paradise
exactly the opposite can be said and so
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says here
those are the pleasures of this dunya
they don't go beyond that boil it down
that is all the pleasures of the dunya
yet with Allah resides the best of
abodess
with Allah so he didn't have to describe
nor enumerate the pleasures of the
paradise because
he said enough when he said that
paradise is with Allah. That's all you
have to hear. That's greater than any
description paradise could ever have is
that it is with Allah.
Subhan Allah.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Hello, sir.